we've seen celebrities endorsing
products for years you became a
stakeholder and developed your own over
the last few why make this change you
just wanted to make more dough well no
the opposite apparently no you know I
think that it's I I started questioning
being hired as a face for companies to
represent and I always worked with
companies that I respected and that I
was a customer of anyway but I started
to question you know as I'm doing this
business on the side and building this
brand you know what what would it be
like if I were to channel the power of
that into my own brand and to kind of
that that the equity be not only you
know it would be sweat equity that I put
into the company but also my actual
equity and and wouldn't it possibly be
more meaningful for me in the long run
if it was a business that I own the
significant share of did you realize you
would be taking on so much more risk I
didn't I was a fool I had no idea what I
was getting myself into but it's been I
have to say it's been incredibly
rewarding and I learned so much every
day and we're in a really exciting time
in the business right now and it's
amazing to be you know the creative
force and also to be understanding
what's going on on the fiscal side and
with raising money and all of that it's
it's very challenging you know it's um
it's a it's a side to me that I didn't
necessarily know that I possess what has
fundraising been like for you I mean
traditionally people know and love going
to paltrow everyone likes you everyone
is your fan but then you had to sit
across the table from VC guys and
bankers and potential investors and say
you might like me but do you want to
invest in me what has that been like
it's um it's definitely been an
interesting experience out of my comfort
zone you know I come obviously my
pedigrees the entertainment business
it's a much different business and it's
it's um it's vulnerable and challenging
and wonderful and exciting to put
yourself in a situation where you know
you're laying out
your idea and your numbers and your open
rates and your revenue and seeing you
know that people are interested in
becoming involved in the business and
becoming partners with you in the
business I still struggle with it
ideologically a little bit only because
you know when those VCS come in then
you're sort of you know beholding to
them and the bottom line so you know I
have trepidation about it but it's also
it's also exciting scoop has gotten
criticized before for not understanding
the consumer but is it the consumer that
doesn't understand because you know who
you customer is and she might not be
mass-market I think that there is
sometimes some miscommunication you know
we we aren't a super luxury site but
we're aspirational we have things on
there that cost $4 we have things on
there that cost you know $500 and I
think sometimes there's sometimes I
think that the some of the criticism
that GUP gets is because people haven't
actually gone to the site and looked
around and see what we actually are now
that you actually are invested in some
products does it make it hard for you to
recommend other businesses that you
don't have a stake in I don't think so
because first of all what will always
you know the core of our business is the
authenticity and the trust and the
reason why our open rates are so high
and a reason why people come back and
back and back is because they trust us
they trust that the information is good
they trust that a recommendation is real
and so we know that at GUP and we will
never do anything to breach that trust
but there are ways you know we've we
figured out that we can actually run a
business and generate revenue they're in
line with the specific brands the ethos
of those brands and what we're trying to
achieve one thing I notice about goop
your face isn't everywhere if I looked
like you all it would be would be
pictures of me on Twitter Instagram and
the website and I know your voice is
there and your influence but we don't
see you everywhere how come I very much
want goop to be its own standalone brand
I know that at this point in time it's
inextricably linked with me but we
really are a team
amazing people who bring incredible
ideas to the site and it's not only me
and you know my dream would be that in
in 20 years people would sort of
recollect that I maybe had something to
do with it at one point and you know my
my involvement would be less less
essential and I think that's what we're
building towards and I think we're doing
it and it'll be interesting to see you
know I never wanted to do a proprietary
brand I wanted it to be its own thing
you know that my my children can run one
day if they want to all right your
toughest job getting your dream role
getting investors to back GUP getting
customers to want to go on to goop and
buy product or getting your kids to do
their homework toughest job definitely
getting Moses to do is homework that's
my toughest job for sure huh